the Supreme Court seat vacated in
February with the passing of Antonin
Scalia uh has created a sort of
firestorm that has exposed the levels of
obstructionism that we can all expect if
Hillary Clinton is the next president of
the United States President Obama
nominated Merrick garland to replace
Antonin Scalia really a very moderate
and and quite frankly pro-business
nominee to be a Democratic president
nominee and Senate Republicans refuse to
hold hearings saying you know what we're
gonna wait we're going to wait because
we want the American people to vote for
president before we decide on who is
going to replace Antonin Scalia now that
is absolutely ridiculous Americans
already had elected president obama to
decide on Supreme Court nominees from
January of 2013 through January of 2017
all known also known as President
Obama's second term but we were told as
soon as we have a president clinton or a
president Trump republican said we'll be
able to move forward with confirmation
hearings apparently unless its president
clinton the republicans are starting to
move the goalposts by suggesting maybe
Antonin Scalia seat will remain open
indefinitely if Hillary Clinton is the
next president of the United States we
have Arizona Republican Senator John
McCain who said quote I promise you that
we will be united against any Supreme
Court nominee that Hillary Clinton if
she were president would put up that was
on the radio uh couple of weeks ago I
mentioned this last week or the week
before we then had Texas Republican
senator Ted Cruz telling reporters that
there was a quote long historical
precedent for having a court with fewer
than nine justices and most recently
North Carolina Republican Senator
Richard burr told a private gathering of
Republicans in North Carolina that quote
if Hillary becomes president I'm going
to do everything I can do to make sure
that for years from now we are still
going to have an opening on the Supreme
Court this really would be completely
unprecedented the longest Supreme Court
vacancy on record is 840
one days it's about two years and three
months and you have to go back nearly
200 years to 1844 for an example uh
maybe we misunderstood guys maybe it was
our fault when the Republicans said last
spring that the vacancy should be filled
by the next president I guess what they
meant is the vacancy should be filled by
the next Republican president that's why
the hope was that Hillary Clinton would
win in a landslide that way she'd have
this whole mandate and really that's
getting getting under mine now yeah no
doubt about yeah i mean the republicans
are worried about okay you're increasing
the amount of money for higher education
and her restrictions on second
amendments and fracking and overturning
citizens united but that is none of
which you'll do it but the issue here is
that the whole point of federal law is
to have uniformity and these kind of
partisan efforts to rig membership are
kind of threatening the whole issue of
it not to mention the entire point of
the supreme court having nine an odd
number of Justices is to avoid four to
four ties which now mathematically can
happen at any point i actually heard
someone say Pat uh a couple of weeks ago
that the president should be forced to
replace justices with other justices
that are similar ideologically have you
ever heard of something more absurd that
basically means the Supreme Court can
never change because any Supreme Court
justice that is conservative that
retires or dies uh or or or resigns
needs to be replaced with someone
ideologically similar you're basically
eliminating the the whole point of
having a president pick somebody which
is that they might have a different
political view right of course that's
not the process at all we know what the
process is based on the Constitution the
president appoints and the Senate
advises and consents yeah but there's so
many Republicans who literally only want
Donald Trump to be elected so that they
can rig the membership of the Supreme
Court and get across their agenda what
proves to me that this is not about
Merrick garland or or whoever in
particular is nominated is that
Republican senator Orrin Hatch once said
Obama could easily nominate Merrick
garland who is a fine man and talked
about how great it would be a president
obama nominated someone like merit
Ireland President Obama then went and
nominated not someone like America
garland but America garland himself and
all of a sudden he's no no not good
enough for people like Orrin Hatch this
is about President Obama and Democrats
isn't it I mean I I don't know if I
necessarily agree with that because I
feel like by trying to kind of rig the
membership shouldn't it be less than
about Obama they just want to put across
their own a jet Republicans agenda well
but that I think that that's exactly the
point which is if they said garland
would be acceptable but then when it's
Obama that nominates him he's no longer
acceptable it can't be about agenda
because Merrick garland nominated by a
Republican or by a Democrat is still
Merrick garland isn't he right but if it
was a Republican president who nominated
him do you think it would have been
accepted uh a court I mean if we believe
Orrin Hatch I guess yeah well I think it
has to do with the fact that a lot of
these senators will have to face
reelection and they don't want to go to
their constituency and say they put up a
nominee put forward by President Obama
that is a horribly pathetic I mean that
you're probably right and that is an
angle which always always an angle when
you're in the Senate or house is how
much money can I raise based on what I
do here and will I get reelected but
it's horrifying that that is probably
true uh disturbing will continue
following it maybe someday we'll get
back to nine justices on the Supreme
Court might be nice I've talked about
how people of all ages but particularly
Millennials are owning cars less and
participating more in the sharing
economy and one of the more popular
options is zip car which gets you a car
when you want it when you need it they
offer all sorts of cars SUVs hybrids
whatever you need it includes insurance
and it includes gas you just pay for the
time that you actually use the car and
you can reserve the car online from your
smartphone over the phone then you
unlock it with your zipcard each car
share member reduces their personal co2
emissions by between 1100 and 1,600
pounds per year for our audience zipcar
is offering $25 a free driving credit if
you sign up at joined zipcar dot-com /
David
for our show reduce your carbon
emissions and you're spending on cars
sign up at join zipcar dot-com slash
david